head up the NBA lottery the chance to
draft Zion we wanted to let Knicks fans
blow off some steam after the years of
disparity for the first time I think we
have a chance to draft a franchise
player draft lottery means so much
because it's the it's the first time
that we are actually keeping our picks
in my 32 years of life I actually see
some hope for the future for the next
and for potentially my kids to be next
fans
Ziya would just bring back everything
sports fanatics to think about the
Knicks throughout the 90s just the
promise of having someone like Zion
playing in the garden is that's a dream
come true if we traded away our
franchise player to end up with no top
pick and no free agents I don't I don't
really know what its next thing to do if
they don't get the number one pick yeah
I'm gonna be pissed
[Music]
what is your worst memory of being a
Knicks fan
Game seven 1994 NBA Finals John Starks
not being able to make a three-pointer
the worst memory of being an extent for
me personally is when Reggie Miller
dropped eight points and seven or eight
or maybe nine seconds and then proceeded
to kiss the floor of Madison Square
Garden my worst memory being a Knicks
fan is the time we traded off our fix
for Andre Bargnani
[Music]
finding out that Tim Hardaway jr. got
the contract that he did I was just very
disappointing it's classic Nicks Adam
Ewing finger roll that was Game seven
last shot don't understand why didn't
get my heart broke a million times after
all of the heartbreak after all the
disappointment I'm still a Knicks fan
cuz I love booty I'm still New York
Knick at heart I'm not a bandwagon fan
and so I'll support them for the rest of
my life regardless of their decision
this year it would be very very nice to
have something to get a little bit more
pumped up about one I think going
through all you know everything that
I've been through there has to be
something that happens that's better
than what I've gone through the second
reason is like who wants to be a nuts
man really I just love the energy which
says something because even Lance Thomas
is incredibly boring play can't keep me
away I always believed that in order to
experience joy you got to experience
pain and yes it's been a lot of pain
being a Knicks fan
but eventually God willing it will all
come out great at the end
or not